it's Christmas we should celebrate they  said  just a little get-together for the  employees have a few drinks blow off a  little steam nothing crazy  Merry Christmas Jeremy great night huh  this is a sample cheese Forge for a  holiday mixer tonight I'm sorry you're  having a Christmas party tonight it's  not happening all right it's cancelled  hey idiot I'm looking right at you I'm  telling you the thing is not happening  at all I'm not messing with you hey stop  doing that  all right if you are going to have  intercourse tonight please do not do a  nun company property go into the  rite-aid parking lot we're talking right  ain't baby make it all night one oh  pardon me  hey Santa wanna party I think he meant  to swing they're a little surprised that  uh said our Christmas card oh you it  says Happy Holidays and everything says  Happy Holidays oh [ __ ] I didn't know he  put